the Joe Rogan experience the weirdest
thing those and the audience I have is
so bizarre because that guy will be
there there will be a guy that Pantera
guy there'll be a guy there with I
there's a last summer in I did you know
an acoustic run of and I did it one up
doing a few festivals I show up at one
and I shit you not Joe Rogan it's called
devil slide or devil side devil side
festival it is nothing but the hardest
like I'm sitting backstage with me and
Brian the guy who came with me last time
keyboard player and we're like just why
am I here and we fucking get it man
we're like freaking out we're like yo
they're gonna fucking kill us man
they're gonna kill us I call my manager
I'm cursing them to hi fucking heaven
dude like you motherfucker you don't
even look where you're booking me do you
you just see a check number and you take
it you don't even ask where you just say
yeah we'll do it huh I was like I listen
to where I am and I'm actually get to
the point where it's like I just start
embracing that funniness of it until the
promoters all right there's some things
missing from my rider and they're like
what I'm like I need a Satanic Bible in
a bucket of goat's blood right now I was
like we need to make a sacrifice before
we go out there cuz we about to get
killed and it was the crazy shit so I
fucking I tell my boy and it wasn't
Brian actually was my boy Derek we were
both playing two guitars so uh we go I
go and I just tell him when we go out
there I was like first thing to get
thrown first anything we're fucking up
I'm a layer in there fuck if something
jumps on the stage you just hit him with
the guitar man it's like dead ass I'm
saying this dead seriously like we're
about to get killed right so this band
that went on before us it was like the
bread that gets buttered with bread or
something it was that's literally some
crazy name like that on the bread that
gets buttered or the butter on the bread
or something like that
it was the most hardest like crazy
it ends in the end the lights and this
is the middle of the day by the way too
this is like four o'clock maybe five
o'clock oh man Jesus come on the whole
house clears so like all of a sudden I'm
having a little bit of hope like okay
maybe nobody will just be in here for
our set maybe think I'll just were like
that no we're gonna go get us beer so
they're changing over the set and it
comes with our turn and I'm like the
crowd starts coming back in go out there
and we start playing our guitars and
next thing I know I see all of these
Pantera and crazy metal dudes and they
got chicks with them now and it goes
over like fucking gangbusters that's
amazing I was like we and we we
literally got offstage dumped we didn't
say words to each other we got in our
van we didn't even set up merch at this
place because we're like nobody cares
we're here we sold like probably a box
emerged out the back of the van with
people catching us cuz we were just you
know Derek we're sitting in the back of
the van just like did that just happen
man that was I wonder that was one of
the craziest gigs I've ever done in my
life that's fascinating that they just
changed gears like that for and it was
no other thing like that it was it was I
never I was just blown away about how it
went and the way it went over I was like
wow dude that was crazy they really dug
it that's a cool story that must've been
a cool experience so if my audience is
crazy be an old lady there'll be like
kids they'll be you know the House of
Pain you know roughneck hooligan guys
still hanging on for that to come back